so today we're gonna look at bromine so
this is bromine it's a small sample
about two or three grams
yet bromine is a red liquid there not
many elements the directly liquid cesium
mercury gallium and bromine it's this
beautiful red color and it has an
unpleasant smell bromine comes from the
Greek word BrahMos which means a stench
a really horrible smell in fact this
bromine probably comes from near where I
did my degree because in Europe the
second world the largest producer of
bromine in Europe is the octal company
which is based on M look on anglesey and
it's actually where I went last weekend
so it's a nice sample we're going to get
it out of this bottle now it's sealed in
because it's obviously very very
volatile the liquid and we're going to
cut the glass get it out and then look
at its chemistry thanks Neil
bromine is also quite a common element
in the world it is found in seawater as
bromide it's also found particularly in
the Dead Sea on between Israel and
Jordan where it's they're very
concentrated solutions of bromide so you
can make bromine just by bubbling
chlorine into a solution of bromide like
dead sea water and the chlorine
displaces the bromine and MEK forms
chloride and the bromine just comes out
as red fumes which you can catch so Neil
is now using a glass knife to open the
ampoule and he's going to pour the
liquid bromine into this small
evaporating dish inside our fume hood
now instantly you can see the vapor of
the bromine coming off you see oh
there's no really nice orange fumes
which are coming off from the liquid and
then they're being drawn away by a fume
hood bromine has a number of uses it is
particularly used in plastics as an
additive to try and make them less
flammable if you're watching your videos
for the room on the screen which has a
plastic surround almost certainly that
surround will contain bromine to make it
less flammable bromine itself is
strongly Oxford
so we thought we do an oxidation
reaction today and that reaction is to
take another element and here we have
aluminium simple aluminium foil like you
wrap your dinner in and we're now going
to put some small amounts of aluminium
foil into the bromine liquid so we'll
put it in and it generally takes a few
moments for this reaction to start but
as I said the aluminium is strongly
oxidizing it oxidizes and generates
aluminium tribromide which is a
beautiful nice material but it's a
strongly exothermic reaction so let's
see what happens now this may initiate
it is also an unusual element because
elements have different isotopes these
are new same form of the elements but
with different numbers of neutrons in
the atoms so they weigh different
amounts usually you get one isotope that
is very common another one that is only
a small amount bromine is unusual
because it has two isotopes 79 and 81
which have almost equal quantities in
nature so that they're approximately 51%
of one and 49% of the other which is
really quite unusual so here we see the
exothermic oxidation and formation of of
aluminium tribromide
so the reaction is strongly exothermic
which means it gives out energy and that
energy then evaporates off excess
bromine which you can see coming off of
the vapor a wonderful exothermic
reaction very very fast very very rapid
forming aluminium tribromide
bromine is quite dangerous but it is
less dangerous than chlorine because
it's a liquid at room temperature
chlorine is a gas so if you let out
chlorine it disperses everywhere with
bromine it is a heavy gas which can
disperse rather more slowly so now as
the reaction calls down we can see that
the volume of bromine is significantly
reduced
you